the gangster from azerbaijan getting it
done today
chakra
we were all on the edges of our seats
watching this game the up down the
swings
what was your feeling playing the game
it just seemed like you had to do
everything you could to keep it all
together okay after finally after to
draw with black i got chance to play
with wyatt of course i want to play some
active games and
some uh trick is some
okay i mean i need to try as a
tournament
and i play i played a good opening but
after i think
i absolutely miss his idea to play is
king fade king is seven because i think
is after queen d forties looks like
winning position for white and white is
winning but after queen d4 he played
king g7 and uh
okay i calculate calculate but i see is
no
no winning position i just miss king g7
uh also i think he he was
it was very nice move for him bishop c6
the inside uh
i was afraid this move when he played in
opening
rook d8
it was very nice move bishop c6 i think
we can show bishop c6 oh sorry sorry
shaq
rook yeah rook the eight rookie one yeah
i uh yeah i play rook c1 i was very
happy because rook t8 i want to play uh
no rook t bishop ca bishop c6 i
calculate a very nice position bishop
take f6 i was very happy because take
take bishop take h7 h7 king h7 queen c2
and here is very strange position
black play f5
queen c6 rook c8 and queen is losing
queen
normal full queen queen december k7
yeah it is very strange i want to of
course i want to take c6 and when i see
okay
after i don't know i think it was very
good position for me i mean
but instead not i start to play very bad
uh
i i yeah and very nice moment for me
when i take knight b5
yeah when i take knight b5
you know
yeah here i was very happy with my
position yeah i played knight d4 knight
b5 yes here is black can play take rook
h2 it's a very strange move rook h2 yeah
we actually analyzed it yeah i i i want
to rock h2 i want to play here queen 83
czech
king g8 i don't know and after kenyat i
want to play knight d4
wow
i wanted to play right now amazing it
was it was very tricky but i don't know
he calculate and i don't know how but i
think it's the only move i don't know
when i play this line i think it's very
very nice winning uh variation but he
play
quick c5 and it was absolutely
not in my plans i mean after queen c5 i
think is yeah
i need to start everything again yeah i
mean and i play not very well till set
not and he miss i think his
rookie six move and after he could have
drawn he could have equalized any time
he wanted to like trading queens for
example yeah yeah
yeah
yeah but uh after f6 is rookie six i
think he's winning position i don't know
oh yeah yeah that's russian yeah but no
but it's very nice variation of the f6
rookie six shaq i just want to interrupt
you for a moment because uh the game was
super super sharp right here because
we didn't understand as much queens he
said but it's not he's because he want
to play rook c5 rook h2 right right but
that's just only part of the story yeah
but there's only only 30 seconds yeah
it's easy you you remember my games
against him in blitz tournament yeah i
asked
1000 i missed
this looks like same rook b two check
rook b one check or rook take a straight
yeah
yeah i think
but here you have knight f3 yeah i mean
i sure yeah it looks nice and also uh uh
is move after uh f6 yeah you know
queen b2
b2
i think he missed queen c6 yeah roxy no
not queen c6 i think he missed quincy
six very nice move knight e4
well yeah if the key for rook c5 is just
winning very nice if rookie four is rook
they give i think he miss uh his idea
knight e4
okay
but
right now we've been showing a lot of
beautiful stuff for you
what do you think about this move
uh okay i'm not calculate this one is
because it's time problems yes yes
for both sides what is the idea
rook h2 and queen
p5 is not just one second this looks not
winning easily or which move sorry
queen h4 yeah
rook p7
and rp7 is not winning
wow
can give one
fantastic h8 is hanging uh
b7 is hanging but it was very tricky
moment wow
right here
here
okay oh come on it's very nice okay very
very okay
because i can't kill the computer i mean
the message is all i get what the heck
is that shackle
we were trying yeah we're desperately
trying to understand this game also one
very nice moment is very nice moment
after uh he play f6 i take his sixth
yeah it's very tricky if not set not
take and the rook g3
yeah is k king if not king fan takes g3
queen g3 is only one way queen g3 king
f1 rook h1
k2 and this bishop f3 it's fantastic
it's only one move is bishop f3 and the
if knight f3 queen g2
and he's taking queen mai and this
yeah it was very strange and this is
only one move is kingifan okay i mean is
it when this one is after set note and
then i have time and they calculate
it's okay do you think you would have
found queen e5
if you had
to make that move on move 40 instead of
move 41. it's very interesting queen e5
is only one move or not
yeah no but this looks very strange
queen e5 is i
first i think knight e4 but night after
knight e4 he can play very nice move his
bishop
uh uh yeah he's just a queen f6 knight
six king is seven and he's a draw yeah
but he played four but his
way is losing yeah it's very interesting
because if he play rook g2 right yeah
his only move is i play knight e4 right
bishop a6 b5 bishop b5 take queen b5
queen e6 and here is not easy to win
it's only one way i think because if i
play rook d8 rook d8 king g7
rook d7 king h6 uh king h60 rook d6
queen 6 96 rk2 is draw
okay yeah it's a draw but i need to play
with not
this one
i i need to play
queen bed on the chest
king g7 king c7
queen c7 is queen h8 rook the eight
looks jade is queen h2 only win
because rook
yeah i take rook
that's stylish yeah he's winning these
guys are good
not bad
are you warming to the brilliancy prize
now maybe no i'm telling you why i
picked shaq as my winner for the
tournament
look he's showing is not made believers
out of you guys yet
love it fantastic that was a great game
indeed wow you're chasing wesley uh
right now for the tour title
but all of these guys are playing so
well what do you feel about the
excitement in this tournament
okay
of course
obviously maxime and
fabiana is top players in the world is
absolutely normal when they played very
well
it's problems i think i need to play
well like uh
this trip is a plus two me plus one but
okay we will try more sixth games uh we
have good chance to play show good chess
and good results show a good chance
right now congratulations you kept us on
the edge of our seats
best of luck in the rest of your games
thank you very much thank you shaq it
was a